I think we have an example
where I originally came out of Pacifica
was founded in 1949 in Berkeley,
California by a war resister named Lou
Hill.
He came out of the detention camps and
he said there has to be a media outlet
that is not run by corporations.
That profit from war,
um,
that has not run by corporations.
As George Gerbner,
um,
founder of the cultural environment
movement,
former dean at the Annenberg School of
Communications,
University of Pennsylvania said not run
by corporations that have nothing to
tell and everything to sell that are
raising our children today.
So pacifica was born the first station
KPFA in Berkeley in 1949.
Second station 10 years later in Los
Angeles,
59,
uh,
Kpf k 1960 Wbai in New York,
1977.
WPFW in Washington and 1970 K PFT and
Houston.
Those are the five Pacific istation's.
Um,
they are the original models of listener
sponsorship that you turn to the
listener and you say,
please,
if you appreciate what you hear,
you don't have to agree with everything.
But if you appreciate this forum for
people to debate and discuss the
critical issues of the day,
please support it.
Um,
KP of t when it went on the air in 1970,
um,
within a few months,
uh,
the small station Houston was blown off
the year.
Um,
the Ku Klux Klan blew it up.
They strap dynamite to the base of the
transmitter.
And I don't know if it was the exalted
cyclops or the Grand Dragon because I
often confuse their titles,
but they said it was their proudest act,
I think because they understood how
dangerous Pacifica is dangerous because
it allows people to speak for
themselves.
And when you hear someone speaking for
themselves,
it breaks down the bigotry,
the hatred,
the characatures that fueled the hate
groups.
I think that is a very important model.
Now,
public radio and television adopted it.
National Public Radio and PBS,
you know,
we all know the listener and viewer fund
drives on the air,
but they tended to move away from that
and they're going to corporate
underwriting.
Um,
uh,
more and more.
But Pacific has remained true to that
idea of listener sponsorship.
And I think that is a critical model,
um,
for authentic,
independent media in this country
around.